hi guys and welcome back to my channel
for those who don't know me i'm luca
ampariello from lucanamparelo.com and
i'm a language coach who helps people
learn foreign languages better faster
and with more joy and now onto the
content
of the video itself one of the best
things that you can do when it comes to
language learning is fundamentally
to learn through comprehensible content
meaning
simply put content that you can
understand
there's a lot of content out there on
the internet but
a lot of this content is just in the
language without
any grammar explanations or any
translation so for example
if you're looking for anything on
wikipedia
and here you have an example of napoleon
bonaparte
a napoleon in italian you can see that
this text is entirely in italian so
if you're a beginner or even an
intermediate learner it might
be tough to understand the every nook
and cranny of the text itself so how do
you make the
incomprehensible or partially
incomprehensible comprehensible
here's one tool or a couple of tools i
want to show you today
that are going to do just that let's
start
with echo echo which is a website
uh it's a radio station based in moscow
and i went directly
to the um the session
here the interview sessions that you can
find here once you
you put you know the url so here you
have the interview
top 10 interviews and i uh selected
which i i always watch um again you
don't need to speak russian
uh you don't need to be learning russian
this is just an example of how to
transform the incomprehensible into
comprehensive when you can apply 20 text
on the internet i will show you in a
second how to do that also
with chinese which has an extra
extra twist to it let's let's let's put
it this way
so here you can see that you can
read the text you can listen to it you
can even download it you can watch it if
you want to but let's suppose that you
have the audio and you have
the text now for those who have an inter
even
intermediate level this text is going to
be difficult because
the lady who talks here she just throws
jokes and
the language is complex i would say this
is content
aimed at native speakers but first of
all you have the text
and then what you can do in order to
transform this text
and make the incomprehensible
comprehensible is the following let's
suppose that i'm gonna
you know right now i'm gonna select a
part of the text i could select all of
it but just for the sake of simplicity
i'm gonna
select a part of it and take a look at
what i'm gonna do now i'm just gonna
double click
and then i'm just gonna click on in
translator which is a google
chrome extension that you can easily
find and
add to your google bar
and then i'm gonna select inline
translation translate selection
to english and ta-da as you can see
uh this uh chrome extension is going to
translate
the text into english or any other
language that you can select you just
have to
manually um set up the translation stuff
it's relatively easy you can find
tutorials on the internet
so basically once you have this as you
can see
this chrome extension translates the
text in your
target language which is russian into
english or any
language that you know well and when you
have this
you can do a number of things you can
listen to the text for example in
russian while you're reading it in
english first
or you can listen to the text in russian
while reading it in russian you can
check every line you can even read the
entire text in english
first to get a sense of it to understand
what this is all about and then just
listen to the text in russian so
you can really experiment once you have
a text a bilingual text
in your target language and your native
language or language you know well
you have the audio possibly even the
video then you can do
all sorts of things with it and this
is exciting now let me show you another
um
you know thing that you can do let's
suppose now that you have the problem of
also reading the text here you don't
have the problem of reading
oops of the problem of reading this text
because once you learn
to how to learn how to read cyrillic
this is
relatively straightforward but with
chinese you know
you have chinese characters so if you
want to make your life easier
and transform this into comprehensible
content
let me click on one random piece of news
and as you can see here you have the
text
in in chinese so what you can do is you
can select the text for example
and you can choose to translate a part
of it
again here into english
so as you can see the text
now has two versions has the part in
chinese and the part in english but you
can also
do something else i have here annotate
so this is a website which is called
chinese annotate
and or chinese annotation and it allows
you to basically
create at any text that you have here
you can put it directly
into this box and it transforms it into
pinyin and on top of that as you can see
here
you also have the explanation of each
and every part it is just mind-blowing
and i have made sure that now that you
can bookmark it
you can bookmark it so that basically
you have it here on the browser
and you just need to click uh just once
and ta-da look at this so you have the
text
you have the text with the chinese
characters you
have the text where you can just hover
every single part and it gives you the
explanation plus you have the pinning
plus you have the translation
and then you can decide if you go here
you can just print it
and this is comprehensible input at its
best
this is just mind-blowing i wanted to
um first of all i wanted to say i i
truly hope that this is going to be
useful for you remember that if you can
minimize the friction of understanding
texts
it that's that's what you're what you
have to aim for
because otherwise it takes more and more
time the first thing
that you have to do is just to try to
understand the text as soon as possible
and the second thing that i wanted to
say is that i wanted to thank personally
thank
look at all my locators a great friend
of mine who
every now and then actually quite often
comes up with
not only with great resources but also
with very creative ways of
using them i'm going to put a
link in the description box related
relating to his website he has a website
that in which he coaches people to learn
japanese
he's a i i think one of the best coaches
in the world when it comes to japanese
and you should definitely check his
website and he has amazing
he has amazing um you know pieces of
advice here
is his website just in case you want to
check it but again i'm just going to put
a description a link in the description
box
and you can find a lot of interesting
content you can see here the
testimonials and
you should definitely check these
articles because they're very well done
and they go very much into depth about
not only comprehensible content but also
going through you know step-by-step
processes of understanding and
dissecting
the amazing japanese language so with
that in mind
thanks uh having said that thanks a
bunch
let me know what you uh what do you
think in the
in the comments and i will
see you soon bye and happy
[Music]
you